Clint is in Illinois hi Clint how are
you hey how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up okay I'm
kind of hard seeing and I got quite a
bit of money
for my age really some other things
anyway I was wondering what suggestions
you have to invest yeah I know they're
going to be real fun
okay having a little bit of trouble
hearing you're going to talk directly
into your phone how much money do you
have
uh probably closer to 25,000 and I'm
getting the checking in the other day
and you're getting a check in the mail
today yeah I sold a boat so I'm gonna
have a lot more cash now and I'm trying
to decide what to do it at all
okay and what is your income sir uh
22,000 what are things that you are
planning to do over the next you're 19
years old over the next five years by
the time you're 24 I don't know I saw a
collagen as a college in your future I'm
going to college right now in Community
College I don't know what I'm going on
or not
okay and uh what about a car are you
gonna need a car yeah I have it so are
you gonna need a new car during the next
five years now I can get on that okay um
well I think the money the probably the
best investment that clinic can make is
in Clint and so I would encourage you to
finish your four-year degree assuming
that you're studying something that can
actually be used in the marketplace I
mean you're studying a degree field that
you've checked it out you know what the
pay is and it's going to be worth your
trouble to study it
don't spend four years getting a degree
that allows you to make eighteen
thousand a year that's stupid yeah but
you spend four years getting your degree
that allows you to enter the market and
make a lot more than you're making now
initially and have a great upside
potential as well and as long as you're
doing that the best money you can spend
is on education and I would keep that
money available for education I would
set it in a separate money market
account and I would lay out a schedule
for my education and completed as soon
as possible and knock out a solid
four-year degree that I'm paying cash
for no debt
Clint paying cash as we go and you about
got the money to finish school if you're
careful and watch what you're doing
especially if you work some while you're
doing it and apparently you're not
afraid of hard work you've done very
well
congratulations sir this is the Dave
Ramsey show you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others